can I join that why not I'm not in yet
but sure okay I'm joining oh you better
know fuli's I think we've already done I
think I've already done this what I
don't think this is the right man but
joini laughs no no this is a prank bro
there better not be any guffaws this
isn't the mouth brother Tojo cards but
no Jew Falls I've got you know the will
jokes not good dude I've got bras in
Atlanta brawl it's me um bumpers yeah
remember how you were insulting me last
time maybe maybe a compliment to hold us
off would be nice on this map before
it's apparent is sassy we're going McKee
oh thanks your accent is not nearly as
funny as people make it out to be
it's actually cool and probably voted
the number one sexiest accent in the
world it is also terrible at it oh wait
my accent is it really isn't it the
northern accent that's the sexy one
no they don't care they're not Irish to
British oh whoa [ __ ] people apples going
to Waffle House all right I'm waiting
awful house yeah there's a [ __ ] a
tipos you just standing in there is that
one of those I can actually go in we've
got one of those in there as well you
can't go exactly you shouldn't this is a
spooky bath whoa what the [ __ ] you like
this face no visible what the flag make
your face isn't oh yeah Jesus
all right wait do it again if they're
yours is in this one
which one of these is in here your than
one of these no I'm not the horror game
dude oh my god I remember that Photoshop
that it's showing I remember that oh
shoot again oh my face no you sudden up
come here
okay okay I'm going to that scary
grammar frequently Popeye right here
looking in the windows with you guys but
oh yeah okay okay nope nope that's not
me that's not me don't worry about it
what is some weird
you [ __ ] I love the bar guys [ __ ] did I
miss with that I don't know don't under
my feet and I immediately wait oh god oh
here we go
where is he I'm not important here hey
there is out here you're not giving me
business community to Nike all right for
this one rule we have to chase people
otherwise nothing will happen I was
asking you that entire time we have to
stay out that Idol this map is so big or
what yes are you thinking about oh you
were thinking what I'm thinking okay we
could think it'd be a really good way
are you guys thinking what Bob and
everything I can smell the dickery
through the internet right now yes you I
mean I showered last night I'm not sure
if it's me well that's the nitration
here not your dick leanness oh okay yeah
work at all the room right there's two
dudes I counted on his stupidity in our
defense there were two bottles right
there so we threw off I really like you
nothing officer Chris I'm the author
who's that I committed that killed for
whatever I committed God okay Bob I
smelled the dickory - yeah yeah you were
all over that yeah you can find wash
yourself Dicky dick everything for how
broke my leg oh there are better way to
be advices [ __ ] front door guys oh
[ __ ] oh for some money hobbling around
outside or breaking their legs no
nothing I was being an idiot oh hey wait
door how spoopy where are we on this
hole [ __ ] we're pretty spoopy we're
bringing by say you guys skeletons is
here you get my piece poopy and
in a minute wait a minute guys wait wait
a minute guys
oh you knocked me over you do that I
stay out here for ten buddy okay I got
what the [ __ ] - ik [ __ ] - anybody
Jews 6000 million I think we're going to
have to upgrade this to a to spook this
might be too spooky for me it is to
white because it is inside you it's
gotten oh you know what you know how to
read
I do you know how to read the sign that
means you're close yeah here baby open
the doors the same poster in another
place no no no no no oh dear Jack I
found on Jeremy like that oh sorry man
let's go watermelons are my enemy Oh No
hey I made it your good wall that's not
something I want
oh hey what about something I want to
hear [ __ ] Jesus is the watermelon out to
here melon
okay are you [ __ ] still inside that
house yeah yeah about you'd be nicer to
us well I was going eventually so I can
see you idiot get mom's hint I'm inside
of that house you're chasing
alright I thought about that yeah losers
I'm usually don't want to forget that
wait a minute I was chasing you in that
house and I was one of those bottles of
bleach in the bathroom that you looked
right at and I was just about to drink
you know I was just trying to milk it
for all it's worth
oh whoa what the [ __ ] I'm like why 400
or 1 back oh I'm back yeah now look up
at the window uh-huh now back up back up
till you're against the wall by the door
hey you weren't going hey hey looking
good what he was underwater
oh that's the windows I was smashing and
you said I was dumb who said well yeah
but yeah I was going in the house oh I
love this Joe Bob oh he's back in the
house
no you know is it all the door noises
giving it away for you or what no
there's a billion shot here your
footstep a silikal
rocks bleach maybe that's a firm
negatory on the bleach Aroo why don't
you just drink some of me because he's
stuck
suck it finding gut damn it [ __ ] you
back at you know I'm actually just 4x
leech okay oh you got them well you
described illusion help assess I've got
that room I didn't think you'd be so if
I'm internally schooling barriers
Heather I knew Morse was a trash can I
got scared remark with the trashcan not
that I was laying our net right I smell
what's coming out your [ __ ]
I smell your stink you smell that stuff
leaking out of my news scoot have you
done something new to your shrink
that's a nice shrink data bub just 100
think clean and minty fresh banks going
broke oh not so good buddy the pen can
know I'm not your ten Kings are all good
sound your attempt can we're all pin
time all tin can can can be involved no
Phil out here he's running around like
crazy ah [ __ ]
there you go great I'll let you run
around so you tried to go inside
oh sure okay all right sure yeah
whatever
oh my god me Andy dumb god the only
reason they got me is cuz they come oh
alright pop unless Oh Jack which one are
you
I'm neither of all of them doc just
opened the door on me hey open several
doors ha ha ha oh you're so stupid
Bob did you open this door here what
door this one hey I found him right here
within the green room right now he's
trying to run away but he's not now he's
in the bathroom like a dumb now he's at
home he's odd close the doors on him no
I did
hi everybody open dude what wow you guys
are awful there's so much line-of-sight
here ah you've made a good gosh darn
fool of that [ __ ] you see poetry your
daddy bad shards of glass on the ground
like yeah I really get you - ha ha ha ha
ha ha on a scale of wrong place selling
machine in the wall whorehouse cry you
alright [ __ ]
alright yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh Lord
you have to be a pilot he's under roof
he's on the roof oh yeah the roof well
what are you oh my homegirl Jacqueline I
don't know lead giving a big me plead I
read it we will watch I just don't know
where he's going oh never mind I don't
need to watch anymore no he's nice too
but he could have left
oh hello hi hi Bob oh hang on wait pause
I had an idea but I could go it will
stop running like we're gonna pop all
right I'm here we're gonna run hang on
what's up oh hey iPod I'm gonna go over
this way okay alright okay slow slow
okay I'm not sure why I'm not shooting
at you
alright no I want to try and get into
the treehouse to be the big pumpkin okay
alright um you know what I trust you you
know I usually don't drug view but I
don't know why he wouldn't touch me I
don't know why either you know like I'm
gonna take the sidewalk so you can see
me the whole time okay cool I'm ready
for this this is cool good stuff
because this is really night I feel
together I feel like really to get okay
I can't get into the treehouse from here
also I'm crying right now because my eye
is watering but I don't want to give up
on this idea
okay I'm gonna tree a ladder or go up
okay buddy you're up there hi oh you
can't become this pumpkin oh I literally
cried for that [ __ ] to happen oh I'm
sorry
what the hell is happening my eyes it
hurts little sinner rub them earlier ass
wagon I didn't trash my cornea Wade
asked what is always in Raich are you
[ __ ] chariot of Pizza Hodge hi Jesus
I mean come in out from there yeah yeah
you should be good
mark Lori mark where'd you go maybe less
good now Marcus is like where the [ __ ]
did he just go he just hired you to do
with him I don't know I don't know
they're a bunch of bots and every door
is open he could have left at any point
no no no no I'm a dork no it really
didn't work well for him that's all I'm
saying
I think I know where Mark is actually
where wait wait say it out loud now tell
you if you're right
you didn't the big pit where the giant
skeleton is whoa you are incorrect
hahahaha I'm in the big pit thinks that
you even have a brain oh oh you I was
like who's throwing some market right
there
he's a bottle he's on the other side of
that fence I know uh no he's by babies
ascenders all no Harold
you just killed a stranger dumb yeah I
think we're bad at being processed hmm
I think all of us might be idiots I did
pretty good I I gave him the wringer
when I was in the building and escaped
he did again this yeah yeah we didn't
get the old um wringer I said shoving
[ __ ] around
I'll start inserting things in my ass no
they don't do it didn't know did you do
what I think you did no it's fine this
is fun so what all man oh man I heard
another door oh no that was me upstairs
did you get good okay glad we mark up
here don't worry yeah are you covered in
goop juice the door down here opened and
someone left Oh
much gusto plasm everyone what the [ __ ]
whoa happy bleach again that's a little
extreme I didn't mean to be bleached I
was a paint can and I accidentally
became bleach all right I was trying to
become a frying pan but you can't be
those okay weighty when were yet weighty
whoo I thought in the [ __ ] room a
doll all round around pentagram of doll
can can you find him so duh can you find
him I get it man of so Chuck can you
find him he's a sodac an evening
literally running laps around someone
right now in a not too obvious but kind
of funny way okay indoors outdoors mmm
there's still two minutes left
well I saw something blue I like the
goddamn lady saw something one way
doesn't give a [ __ ] about doors he opens
under closes them what's going away huh
even eight anymore so you're on your own
with that I got a Granada hide please
please wait whoa I was doing the cycle
man no no no I don't think you were not
I intend on time Jack heard a door opens
like oh that's me upstairs as a ghost it
was me I broke my game it's constantly
vibrating awesome hahaha
Wow jump out of the tree Hudson no yeah
that you got jumped for the hill that's
what I did before that was mine there's
also a stack of boxes on the backside
across the fence you think why do you
immediately jump off cuz you came up and
why you throwing things out of that tree
house come on don't be so rude oh it's
not rude this he's a prop so rude
hey I see you on that I see on there on
that tree top the tree house I see you
you see you see you right now
yeah hi wait my hobby or no hurts well
I'm not in the treetops dummy now you're
out picking up water McQuaid then
whoever that is good stuff there goof oh
what a goof shot what a good me guys
what I got is a pervert about what a
Dean one sec straight up roof straight
up goof men
ah [ __ ] Wow were you looking at me and
did not look like you were looking at I
was looking at you I was watching you
slide to the last year's mil you walked
it in a ladder I know yeah but I was
like it was like you were looking
straight out the whole time when I was
going damn it comes down to this
what comes down - gosh this is the
pivotable pivot pivot little thing you
okay Bob yeah do it
oh I see a toilet maybe this is a
walking toilet will be with the top of
art the top part wearing my side Jack
I'm literally standing right in front of
you right now
come on me not when you turn to your
left now I'm standing right behind you
now I'm standing right to your right oh
hi how's it going guys Brigid you nose
all right tonight I'll be in a toilet
I'm Tita I mean pretty cool actually
I've read a lot of value to this
treehouse you being a toilet yeah there
wasn't a toilet in this treehouse hi hi
all right that's embarrassing did you
get scared because Jack was coming yeah
because my back ladder escape oh we
gotta go we gotta vote I'm not voting
never mind we're not voting
[Music]